anyway so I noticed this trend again of
the amazing
wives and mothers and women of um my
generation and the generation above me
um seeking validation um
so there was a guy named Travis on
Twitter and he tweets apparently this is
considered plus-size I don't see it
she's absolutely gorgeous thoughts and
Billy says Y'all Scared to date women
over 145 and it's effing annoying now
guys that lady's fat I don't know what
to tell you I mean she's still beautiful
like I'm not there's some pretty fat
chicks but it's the exception it's not
the rule she'd be way hotter if she was
thin it's honestly like a waste of
beauty imagine you could be that hot fat
and like like if anything guys this
shows how valuable beauty is it's like
it and it she's wasting it right so okay